momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello me acompaña nuestra
periodista daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches américa latina' tardaría
al menos dos años más en recuperarse
económicamente porque hola andrés qué
tal el fondo monetario internacional
dice que eso se dará en 2023 en el mejor
de los casos la razón principal es el
fuerte impacto de la crisis sanitaria en
el empleo el organismo destaca que las
pérdidas han sido principalmente para
las mujeres los jóvenes y los
trabajadores informales para este año se
espera un crecimiento del 4,1 por ciento
para la región pero no hay que
desconocer que más de 17 millones de
personas han entrado en situación de
pobreza
daniela y aumenta la fiebre por el
bitcoin que alcanzó un nuevo máximo
histórico
así es andrés la cripto moneda se
disparó este lunes y casi toca los 45
mil dólares la razón tiene nombre propio
y lo en moscú el dueño de tesla de quien
hablamos mucho en esta crónica su
empresa anunció que invirtió 1.500
millones de dólares en esta cripto
divisa y que la aceptará como medio de
pago de sus autos de lujo como ya lo
hacen otras grandes como
pero qué es lo que hace tan atractiva
esta moneda que no está respaldada por
las autoridades económicas muchos se
preguntarán andrés el bitcoin que es la
primera cripto moneda y la más grande
nació después de la crisis de 2008 para
que se pudieran efectuar pagos en línea
sin tener que pasar por las
instituciones financieras y de esta
manera ponerlas en jaque hoy en día
existen más de ocho mil cripto monedas y
de solo bitcoin hay 18,6 millones en
circulación lo llamativo andrés es su
precio en sus inicios no valía casi nada
y en 2013 ya costaba mil dólares por lo
que empezó a captar la atención mundial
incluso de las autoridades económicas
que ya están pensando en hacerle frente
con la posible emisión de sus propias
monedas virtuales
daniela y una investigación periodística
mundial apunta a luxemburgo como un gran
paraíso fiscal andrés el prestigioso
diario francés le monde y otros 16
medios internacionales dieron a conocer
este lunes el primero de varios
capítulos que dan cuenta de unas 55.000
sociedades fantasmas creadas en
este país por multinacionales y
millonarios pero también por grupos
mafiosos en su portada como vemos el de
mont define a open looks como una
investigación sobre el lado oculto de
luxemburgo un paraíso fiscal ubicado en
el corazón de la unión europea según
millones de documentos analizados por
varios meses en el ducado de luxemburgo
están registrados desde lujosas
propiedades hasta yates helicópteros
jets privados y obras de arte de unos 65
mil beneficiarios que los tienen allí
precisamente para no pagar impuestos
entre ellos aparecen nombres como el
deportista tiger woods la cantante
shakira o la actriz angelina jolie pero
también tres cuartas partes de las
empresas que hacen parte del principal
índice de la bolsa de parís y
multinacionales como louis vuitton kfc o
amazona pues el gobierno andrés ha
rechazado la investigación y dijo que
tiene afirmaciones sin fundamento
daniela y en bélgica lanzaron una
cerveza solidaria cómo es eso
andrés el gobierno regional de bruselas
que es uno de los destinos cerveceros
por
y lanzó una campaña de crowdfunding para
apoyar a los hoteles y bares que están
cerrados por la pandemia funciona de la
siguiente manera quienes donen recursos
reciben como recompensa una experiencia
en un hotel y una cerveza que fue creada
exclusivamente para esta causa y se
llama surf que significa agrio una forma
de decir que los bares y hoteles no
pasan por el mejor momento pues llevan
más de 100 días cerrados en pocos días
un buen número de locales ya ha recibido
varios miles de euros de sus clientes
que se niegan a verlos desaparecer vamos
con los indicadores daniela wall street
e inició la semana con triple recorte en
sus principales índices el mercado está
muy atento a que se apruebe el mega plan
de estímulos propuestos por joe parte
este resultado también animó a las
bolsas europeas con milán y londres a la
cabeza y latinoamérica a 0 mixta con
ganancias en buenos aires y en sao paulo
y nuestra cifra del día entre 104 y 625
dólares será la multa que impondrá el
gobierno cubano a quienes violen los
precios máximos establecidos por el
estado para los alimentos o quienes
retengan
con la nueva política cambiaria que
entró a regir el primero de enero
algunos precios se han disparado
injustificadamente andrés hablando como
siempre con la información económica
muchas gracias por acompañarnos y
ustedes gracias también por
sintonizarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]